In this video, we're going to walk through how to
package this project into an executable.
After we make all the changes,
let's just quickly review what we
did during the hands-on exercise.
We added one more event here called send string and
integer is an OSC message
that has a string and also an integer.
We also have a send string bundle event here,
which is sending a bundle of two messages,
both contain one string value inside.
Finally, we make sure that our logic
is able to work in both ways communication.
In the sender, we're specifying
the OSC message target based on if it's a sender or a receiver,
and also making sure
the sender also have a server to listen to the OSC messages,
and we react the same way as the receiver from here.
Finally, we made sure we connect
back to the read launch parameter events here,
so we are getting the information from the launch parameter.
Now, we just need to go to
platform and hit Windows and package.
Before that, let's go to the package settings
and see what are the couple of settings we want to confirm.
Inside project, let's first go to Maps and
Mode and make sure that the game default map,
which will be the first map that we will open into in
the packaged game is the correct map we wanted to use.
In our case, it should be OSC example,
and it is using a game mode we wanted to use.
We didn't do anything in the game instance,
so it's okay to remain in the default game instance here.
Now, this part all looks good.
I'm going to go to the packaging part.
In the packaging part,
we can go past everything here.
We didn't do anything special in this part.
We will open the Advanced tab.
Inside here, let's move on to cook only maps.
This is a good practice to check this,
so it will only cook the map we
want to cook and ignore everything else.
It will be a good way to reduce
the package size to have this checked.
Once we checked this,
we want to make sure we have the list
of maps we want to include in a packaged build.
In our case, it's simple because we only have
one map as the default map we are opening to.
By default, this map will
already be included in our packaging list.
But just as a good practice,
we can make sure we also
list it in our list of maps to include.
We can add a map by pressing this plus button,
and we can use a three dot button
here to find the map we want to include,
which will be in the content folder,
this one, open.
Now, we don't need to worry about anything else.
For the build configuration,
because I want to continue to see
the print string, I will leave it as a development build.
If you are running to any weird issue,
you might need to do a full rebuild,
but I'm going to not do
a full rebuild just to speed things up.
If we do it for distribution check,
this will by default change back to be a shipping build.
We're not going to distribute this anywhere,
so I'm going to uncheck it and go back to development.
That should be it.
We can now go ahead,
go to platforms, go to Windows,
and hit package project.
We can specify where we want it to package.
I'll put into packaged and say this will be my result.
I'll hit select folder to start packaging.
Video, we will show you the final result from
this packaged project and
walk through some of the launch parameter settings.